[Música]
se celebró el Día Mundial de la libertad
de prensa un informe de la organización
reporteros Sin fronteras concluye que el
ambiente para el periodismo Es malo en
siete de cada 10 países del mundo y que
la labor periodística se ve amenazada
por la industria de las noticias falsas
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos condenó la violencia policial
durante las protestas
antigubernamentales en Perú la cidh
aseguró que ha encontrado además casos
de ejecuciones extrajudiciales en
ayacucho la presidenta Dina boluarte
rechazó la supuesta existencia de
masacres
y en Colombia el mes de abril de joven
21 líderes sociales asesinados por
diferentes grupos armados y se convierte
en el mes más mortífero en lo que va de
año un total de 55 líderes han sido ya
asesinados en 2023 en medio de los
diálogos que el gobierno Busca en su
promesa de paz total en el país
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos el informativo
con la conmemoración este miércoles del
Día Mundial de la libertad de prensa
France 24 hace una revisión en
Centroamérica una de las regiones más
peligrosas para ejercer el periodismo
nuestro reportero se acercan a los casos
de Nicaragua y del Salvador sus
periodistas sólo encuentran refugio en
Costa Rica más en el siguiente reportaje
coral
es Costa Rica pero también Nicaragua
especialmente para los medios de
comunicación
185 periodistas nicaragüenses han salido
al exilio desde 2018 el caso más
paradigmático es el del diario La prensa
El más antiguo del país con 97 años de
existencia en julio de 2022 toda la
redacción se exilió en Costa Rica Fabián
Medina es su editor un periodista igual
a un narco periodismo y narcotráfico o
algo así un delito grave que se
considera grave
ejercer el periodismo en Nicaragua y se
y se persigue como tal
les confiscaron sus instalaciones y
allanaron sus casas es el caso del
fotorreportero Óscar Navarrete después
de cubrir la expulsión de Nicaragua de
las monjas misioneras de la Caridad se
me llevaron equipos de la prensa y
equipos míos personales entre ellos
computadoras tablet laptop cámara
fotográficas lentes
yo vine acá a este país con un iPhone 7
y eso no me detuvo de seguir haciendo
periodismo gráfico la prensa no ha sido
el único medio perseguido en Nicaragua
22 periodistas han perdido la
nacionalidad como Lucía pinedaubau que
además llegó a estar presa cerca de seis
meses antes de salir a Costa Rica su
medio 100% noticias fue confiscado
también su casa hemos ido encarcelado
hemos sido robados nuestros medios de
comunicación nos han robado la
nacionalidad nos han despojado de
nuestros pasaportes
nos han perseguido incluso la
persecución contra la prensa se filtra
por las fronteras centroamericanas como
en El Salvador de nayib bukele El Faro
uno de los referentes en investigación
de América Latina ha decidido mover su
operación administrativa ilegal también
a Costa Rica Sergio arauz es uno de sus
directivos también forma parte de la
asociación de periodistas de El Salvador
estamos en un momento muy crítico
desde hace algunos años Creo yo que el
buquelismo ha montado un escenario
dispuesto para
restringir la labor de los periodistas y
de los medios Honduras y Guatemala
tampoco escapan de la persecución contra
la prensa convirtiendo a Centroamérica
en una zona roja para aquellos que se
atreven a fiscalizar al poder en Estados
Unidos la policía informó de la
detención del sospechoso de matar a una
mujer y herir a cuatro personas más en
Atlanta el tiroteo tuvo lugar en un
centro médico de la ciudad y
posteriormente el sospechoso huyó en un
coche robado el joven de 24 años y ex
miembro de la guardia costera fue
detenido en un suburbio al norte de la
urbe
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos condenó la violencia policial
durante las protestas
antigubernamentales en Perú que
siguieron a la detención del
expresidente Pedro Castillo la cidh
aseguró que ha encontrado además casos
que podrían constituir ejecuciones
extrajudiciales y que la violencia en
ayacucho debe ser investigada con un
enfoque étnico racial Pues en esta y en
otras zonas del país se han encontrado
ataques contra la población indígena que
en ocasiones no formaba parte de las
protestas anteriormente nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías nos
habló de las reacciones que ha generado
este reporte entre las autoridades
peruanas
justamente la presidenta Dina boluarte
ha rechazado las acusaciones de lo que
se denomina como ejecuciones
extrajudiciales y también masacre la
mandataria ha señalado que como todo
reporte cuestionado no lo comparte pero
respeta la mandataria ha dicho que su
gobierno Respeta los derechos humanos y
ha negado estigmatizaciones hacia la
población indígena por su parte el
Primer Ministro Alberto taruela ha sido
enfático al señalar que el reporte de la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos no tiene ningún tipo de
acusación penal sin embargo ha prometido
establecer mecanismos para que el estado
peruano haga un acompañamiento al
organismo y prometió que se le dará toda
la facilidades Mientras tanto en el
congreso de este país sectores de
derecha señalan de sesgado al informe y
piden que el Perú se retire de la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos y
Abril se convirtió en el mes más
mortífero para los líderes sociales de
Colombia con 21 de los 55 asesinatos
registrados en lo que va de año por la
organización
una violencia que no da tregua en el
país pese a los diálogos del presidente
Gustavo Petro para lograr su promesa de
campaña la paz total en Colombia Marina
sardinha con los detalles
abril el mes más letal para los
defensores de Derechos Humanos en
Colombia Lenin Jaime Diana Luisa son
algunos de los nombres de los 21 líderes
sociales asesinados por su ejercicio de
Liderazgo social en territorio pero
también en las ciudades hemos
documentado 21 asesinatos de Defensores
de derechos humanos y otros líderes
sociales ocurridos en el mes de abril
esa cifra más alta en lo que va del año
en total hemos documentado 55 asesinatos
de Defensores y líderes sociales en
Colombia según Frontline defenders
Colombia representó el 48% de los 186
asesinatos documentados y verificados en
la región de las Américas durante 2022
un conteo diario de muertes de líderes
masacres y persecución a los firmantes
del acuerdo de paz con la guerrilla de
las FARC al menos 358 es guerrilleros
asesinados desde 2016 y unas altas tasas
de impunidad una reciente investigación
de dicha organización apunta a las
causas de esta violencia la falta de
presencia Estatal integral en los
municipios y regiones más afectadas por
la violencia social y política hacen que
el principal factor de riesgo continúe
siendo la generación de disputas
económicas y políticas de la mano con la
existencia organización y
fortalecimiento de estructuras legales e
ilegales Mientras que el presidente
Gustavo Petro está inmerso en los
diálogos para lograr la ambiciosa paz
Total que prometió en campaña una
realidad alejada de los territorios
golpeados por el control territorial de
grupos criminales y el narcotráfico y
pasamos a Brasil donde la policía
federal allanó la casa del expresidente
Jair bolsonaro todo como parte de la
operación venir en la que se acusa al ex
mandatario y a otros sospechosos de
haber falsificado los registros de
vacunación públicos para poder ingresar
a Estados Unidos Alba Santana nos amplía
coches de la policía y agentes acerca de
la casa del expresidente de Brasil Jair
a bolsonaro el motivo una orden de
allanamiento a su casa que se saldó con
la detención de dos de sus ayudantes
como parte de una investigación que
intenta responder a una pregunta
falsificó bolsonaro los registros de
vacunación públicos Y es que a pesar de
que el expresidente de extrema derecha
ha repetido en varias ocasiones que
nunca recibió una vacuna contra el covid
19 aparecen los registros públicos de
vacunación de noviembre de 2021 y
diciembre de 2022 supuestamente para
poder ingresar en Estados Unidos
la policía federal lanzó el miércoles la
operación veniré para esclarecer las
acciones de una asociación criminal
formada para cometer el delito de
introducción de datos falsos de
vacunación contra el covid-19 los
sistemas del Ministerio de salud como
parte del operativo la policía efectuó
16 órdenes de registro y 6 de detención
en Brasilia
de Janeiro y entre los sospechosos
estaba el propio bolsonaro a pesar de
que ha negado haber cometido cualquier
delito
no me vacuné fue decisión personal mía
después de leer el prospecto de pfizer
me sorprende una operación de registro y
una incautación Por tal motivo y no
tengo nada más que decir
esta nueva investigación pone más
presión sobre el líder de ultraderecha
brasileña que ya enfrenta otras causas
por su presión de votantes malversación
y ataques contra la legitimidad del
sistema electoral brasileño
así cerramos este informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]